Call of Duty World War two is a
thrilling return to the series
historical roots and in many ways so too
is its multiplayer traveling back over
70 years to the most infamous conflicts
in history has meant that innovations
seen in recent futuristic installments
have taken a backseat to restrict Lee
boots-on-the-ground
experience but bringing the action back
down to earth is no backwards step world
war 2 offers a lean muscular multiplayer
experience brought to you by Call of
Duty World War 2 when you first set foot
in the multiplayer trenches you'll be
greeted by something new this is your
introduction to the new division system
and your opportunity to choose an allied
division that best suits your playstyle
put simply divisions are a reinvention
of create a class removing the point
system and replacing it with five unique
paths each with their own upgradable
training and skill sets however don't
feel that this is a high-pressure
situation your choice is not permanent
and before long you'll have the
opportunity to use unlock tokens to try
out all the divisions that said let's
take a look at your options from the
outset
[Music]
for all rounders and beginners there's
the Infantry Division this division
specializes in all range rifle centric
combat unique to the division is a
bayonet charge which gives you the edge
in close quarters engagements as an
infantryman you'll also get an extra
attachment for your primary weapon which
promises to make you incredibly
formidable provided your aim doesn't let
you down
as the SMG wielding Airborne Division
you'll get up close and personal with
your grease gun the focus here is on
speed stealth and ruthless efficiency
and it's the only division that grants
you a suppressor for your weapon if you
prefer to keep your distance and provide
fire support the armoured division could
be a good fit the LMG is better deployed
at a safe distance with their large
magazines allowing for effective
sustained fire the addition of a bipod
means that you can get unmatched
stability while prone which can make you
unstoppable if you find the right sight
lines the emphasis on destruction is
bolstered by the m1 bazooka as your
secondary weapon and lethal sticky
grenades
[Music]
Mountain is the sniper division and with
the sniper sharpshooter division skill
it's never been a better time to try
your hand at long-range marksmanship
this skill blocks out anything outside
of the scope while also steadying your
aim and revealing enemy names in the
right hands it's devastating
you can also protect your six with the
bouncing betty s mine and conceal
yourself from player-controlled
scorestreaks like the glide bomb
finally at the other end of the range
scale there's expeditionary for
close-quarters combat the default gun is
a guaranteed one hits kill at close
range and even if you don't finish them
off immediately the incendiary shotgun
shells division skill will contribute
additional chip damage if the enemy
comes around a corner and its greeted by
you it's already too late
whatever your choice of division you can
also apply one of a wide selection of
basic skills although some are clearly
better suited to some divisions than
others for example undercover is a great
match for mountain as it doesn't reveal
enemy death locations and your enemy
won't see your name nor will a reticle
change color if your targeted it's a
sniper's dream divisions level up
independently to your overall player
level so it pays to dedicate yourself to
perhaps just one or a couple at a time
to get those additional division skills
rolling in quicker
in addition weapon levels are back and
will net you a wealth of useful
attachments so find what works best for
you match it to the corresponding
division and watch those deadly extras
come rolling in not to mention those
all-important unlock tokens before we
leave you keep an eye out for the button
prompts in the multiplayer menus the
names of your chosen divisions and even
the Allied nation you're representing
are not set in stone simply press
triangle on the appropriate menu screens
as is being demonstrated here and you
can personalize and customize to your
heart's content Call of Duty World War
two superb multiplayer streamlines some
familiar aspects for greater
accessibility yet with the addition of
divisions provides increased scope for
tactical customization and strategic
play in the next video we'll look at how
this works in practice as we jump boots
first into the all-new War mo
you